alright
[Music]
hello today is tuesday september first
and this is the most important news
of the day the family of a man who
died after a shootout with the
las vegas metropolitan police during a
black lives mara protest is
suing the police department
jorge  Gómez, 25, was shot
outside the federal courthouse in
downtown on June
1. The authorities said that he used
protection and was armed. The officers
asked him to lower his weapons and
he refused. However, the family alleges that
he never  he was a threat and never fired
or pointed at officers the four
officers who shot gomez did not
have body cameras
small businesses will now have another
chance to get
financial help as the
rental assistance program is extended
through september 8 this  includes an
aid of up to 10 thousand dollars for
eligible businesses for more information
visit
the governor  steel became the one that
extended the moratorium on
evictions it was supposed to expire
today but now it won't be for
45 days the governor clarified that he wants to
avoid an eviction crisis in nevada
while residents fight the
virus
and now we're going with the  weather forecast
we will have a clear sky with
some breezes the first day of
september we will start with temperatures
exceeding 90 degrees however
the heat will return with a high of 110
for the weekend and the
leiber tape holiday have a nice
day  greeting andrés gonzález
this was your brief informative the news
nao in spanish
[Music]